hello my name is Garrett Wilde and I'm
the business manager for life science
cameras and microscopy here at andal
the presentation today is going to be on
democratizing confocal microscopy a new
benchtop microscope to boost
productivity
after years of experience of watching
people use our high-speed Con focals in
their research
and watch of them actually use them
increasingly for routine work we thought
what a game changer would be to be able
to take those large confocal systems and
package them into a box small enough to
put into a regular laboratory and make
it part of a routine laboratory workflow
this culminated in our brand new bc43
and or benchtop confocal
many people section fixed samples or
specimens before staining
often this is because it helps with
antibody penetration for example and
subsequent labeling
but also people may section because when
you eventually put them under the
microscope
you're able to see the detail in the
sample more clearly and then you image a
section at a time and rebuild
your understanding of that larger
specimen in the whole
however confocal microscopy
even in samples that where antibodies
don't necessarily penetrate that deeply
would still mean that you could get away
with slightly thicker samples or thicker
sections I should say
and then image them more in 3D
after all life exists in 3D so why image
in 2D if you don't have to
and if you're already familiar with
confocal microscopy
we'll be used to something like one of
these two systems you see in the images
here
they're typically designed for pretty
complex experiments
and are actually fairly excessive for
routine Imaging
they're quite expensive to purchase and
to run they have a large footprint
will typically be found in a core
facility where you have an Imaging
expert to help you they have quite a
long learning curve
and they're often in a specialized room
or require specialized room such as a
dark room
which you may not always have easy
access to
when designing the bc43 we wanted to
make confocal microscopy accessible to
as many people as possible
wanted to make it affordable obviously
we want it to have a small footprint so
it could fit on your bench top and
therefore be part of a high productivity
workflow
we needed it to be super fast to learn
and we wanted it to have low running
costs
as I mentioned earlier we realized that
not all experiments necessarily need
confocal microscopy
so consequently the bc43 is a
multi-modal Imaging system
three Imaging Solutions in one
we have transmitted light microscopy so
this is bright field and a technique
which I'll come to called differential
phase contrast so this allows you to
image unstained samples
then we have wide field microscopy so
this is fluorescence it's a more
conventional fluorescence microscopy
and then if your sample is thick or is
suitable for for confocal Imaging then
we have the confocal microscopy modality
so we give you the benefit of all worlds
depending on your experimental type and
the desired outcome of your experiment
so let's start a transmitted light
microscopy
the most basic form of this is bright
field illumination where you have a
uniform column of light illuminating
your sample and then any natural
contrast in your sample is picked up by
the objective and ultimately in your
final image
this is fine for samples to have natural
contrast in them like plants or small
model organisms like daphnia
however if you have cultured cells which
are transparent then this method is less
useful
for Einstein samples are for samples
that have very little contrast in them
we have developed the unique technique
of differential phase contrast
or what we call DPC
in DPC
we actually illuminate the sample from a
slight angle unlike in bright field
which was a uniform column of light
passing through the sample here the
angle of Illumination means that we end
up with a slightly 3D looking effect of
the sample and I'll show you that
shortly
one of the nice things about DPC is that
there's no need for specific objectives
for those of you who use face contrast
objectives you may or may not be aware
that inside that objective is a phase
ring and the phase ring can cut out some
of the light that comes passes through
the objective for fluorescence Imaging
it's nice to have nothing in the
objective to maximize a signal and
therefore sensitivity for Imaging
and then unlike in DIC we have no need
for polarization Optics which add
expense to the system
so DPC delivers high contrast and high
resolution imaging even in unstained
samples
this is an example of DPC being used to
image a solfish sample
you can see that we can then combine
this with imaging modalities such as
widefield.com focal in this case you can
see it's combining it with confocal
so the DPC does give you an extra level
of detail that you wouldn't otherwise
have in the fluorescent sample alone
the selfish is quite a fixed sample more
challenging would be a monolayer of
cells such as here so here you can see
that we're actually using DPC quite
clearly to image cells both stained and
unstained
and what's worth noting is that DPC
works with plastic dishes
DIC which gives you a similar 3D effect
to DPC uses polarization Optics and
plasticware interferes with that
polarization and so renders DIC useless
so DPC has an advantage here in many
ways
so moving on to fluorescence microscopy
and the most commonly used form which is
wide field illumination
in wide field illumination
again like transmitted light
illumination and bright field you have
an evenly illuminated column of light
shining at your sample but in this case
it's a fluorescence for specific
fluorescence wavelength such as foretic
nanometers for Imaging gfp
in this instance the objective will
capture all of the light that's in the
focal plane of the objective and
additional light that's coming back from
the sample
Widefield systems are extremely useful
for example for thin samples so if the
sample is thin then you don't you can
focus pretty much on the sample and you
don't get too much out of focus
information back from it
it's good for fast events here you have
always have the maximum number of
photons getting to your camera and
therefore you can have the shortest
exposures and the fastest frame rates
it's also very good for live cell
Imaging if you have cells or samples
that are particularly
photosensitive and their physiology
changes with too much light then wide
field can be very gentle illumination
and therefore prolong the life and the
and preserve the behavior of cells when
being imaged
and also it means you can image samples
with very low signal so if you have very
low expression of for example gfp or
other fluorescent proteins in your cells
then by capturing all of the light from
the sample you can get away with
detecting extremely low samples when we
have a sensitive camera such as we have
in the bc43 and handle scmos camera
probably one of the best litmus tests
for phototoxicity of a microscopy system
is actually following cell division
cells are very sensitive to phototoxic
levels of light and they won't divide if
there's too much light and that's
harming them
here you can see bc43 Imaging for 24
hours in this case the cell division is
occurring frequently and consistently
over that time
of course we can image for longer than
that particularly if you put an
incubator on the bc43 as well
so many of us are interested in the
intercellular structure of a cell so for
example actin the cytoskeleton
mitochondria the PowerHouse of the cell
or elements of the nucleus
to see these we need to go to a high
magnification
however the high magnification in wide
field you don't just only get what's in
focus in the focal plane of the
objective but you also pick up the
detailed signal of the in the outer
Focus planes and these contribute to a
final image that has this hazy look
about it
ultimately what we want to do is try and
clear that Haze away but the out of
focus information back where it belongs
and end with a much higher contrast more
detailed image
foreign
there are a number of techniques
well-established techniques that are
called that are known as either
deconvolution image restoration or
digital clearing
and these algorithms are well
established and trusted
and when you apply them
they basically clear up your image
restoring the out-of-focus information
from where it originated and now you
have a much higher contrast more
detailed
high resolution image
if we take a look at this this cell so
this is a cell metaphor that's in
metaphase going through cell division so
it's rounded up so here we've got an X Y
View
here and then we can also see the y z
and XZ view so we can actually see
detail
through its entire structure quite
clearly
and this is the same image here that's
been deconvolved or has had image
restoration done to it
so you can see how much clearer the
detail is in that sample
and the resolution and detail you can
get from a 3D image
so we can image very nicely in wide
field and using the convolution restore
the image that we get a lot of detail
that we wouldn't have otherwise seen and
captured
and we can easily apply this
deconvolution to time series for example
so if we were to image a cell over time
at high resolution at high magnification
I should say for high resolution then we
can just completely deconvolve that in
time type time series and see how the
cell structure is changing over time
and this is just a quick movie to show
you each Z plane as we go up and down
through the sample
showing you the detail in each layer
infusion that controls both our bc43 and
our dragonfly confocal series
we're able to actually capture and
visualize in Real Time 3D data Stacks
Stacks as the Z series are captured from
the microscope
and this is because we have the amaris
visualization engine in Fusion
we can obviously then take those files
export them to Mars and do things like
surface rendering such as you're seeing
here which allows you to inspect your
sample in 3D in much greater detail
and you can then go on to even count
features for example if you're looking
at cancer cells in a population and
treatments you can use Mrs to
count or measure differences between
treatment and control groups and
therefore analyze your data
in much more detail
multiple cells multi-well plates as a
high throughput workflow
okay so I've just shown you that we can
capture fluorescence images
and use deconvolution to give you high
contrast images just using wide field
illumination
so why do you need a confocal
well as you saw even in wide field
images
you do have
background signal from out of focus
information
of course if you could move straight to
confocal it would remove the step of
having to do deconvolution
so giving you the highest contrast and
sharpest images at all times
in addition to that
wide field with deconvolution only
really gets you so far
and as you move to samples that are
thicker than say 30 or 50 microns it
becomes increasingly challenging for
wide-filled microscopy and deconvolution
to work
anything over 50 microns definitely
becomes challenging
and so this is where confocal starts to
benefit because you can go 50 microns
into several hundred microns depending
on your sample and its preparation
this is where Widefield and digital
clearing or deconvolution methods will
start to falter
here is a great example of confocal
working well in a thick sample this
specimen is a 521 Micron thick example
of a cleared solefish
here you can see the wide field image
from that sample
stained in this image are tubular which
is picking up the nervous structure and
myosin which we'll be picking up
muscular structure in yellow
if I now show you the confocal image you
can see how much clearer that confocal
image is you can see the fine structure
here now in the nerve cells and the
neurons and also you're starting to see
the muscular structure as well this is a
10x magnification so it's still at
relatively low mag but you're already
seeing an amazing amount of detail in
what is a very thick sample using
confocal there's no additional
deconvolution here this is purely
confocal on its own you could in fact
decompile further if you wanted to even
in confocal
and here you can see those images side
by side so the White Field on the left
with very little clear detail in it and
on the right hand side the confocal
with its extreme Clarity and contrast in
its image
so at the start of my presentation I
mentioned the fact that not only have we
produced a convenient and easy to use
affordable benchtop confocal microscope
in the bc43 but I also mentioned that it
was high productivity and I haven't
really yet touched on this
in order to explain why it's a high
productivity unit I first of all need to
tell you a little bit about confocal or
the principles of confocal and how that
works
and therefore differentiate between the
technology that we use in the bc43 and
the more commonly used conventional
technology that you're probably more
used to
so let's start off with the confocal
microscope
typically a confocal is using a laser
light source as its illumination using a
point of light
and then that
is hits a dichroic mirror it passes down
through the objective or Optics to the
specimen
and then it passes back up through the
objective
the omitted wavelength which is longer
than the excitation wavelength passes
through the dichotic mirror
and then the light hits a pinhole
and this pinhole is in the light path to
basically only allow
in Focus information through and block
any out of focus information
so in this instance
the red line or the orange line is
indicating out of focus information and
therefore it's getting blocked by this
solid mask either sides of the pinhole
and any in Focus information which you
see here with the green
actually passes through the confocal
pinhole and reaches the detector which
in our case in the bc43 is a scientific
camera
and basically the pinhole is the key
part of a confocal microscope here
now there are
two probably most popular forms of
microscopy systems with pinholes in them
certainly by far the most common one and
most of you are familiar with would be a
point scanning confocal in the case of a
point scanning confocal you have a
single pinhole and a single point of
light Illuminating the sample at any one
time
the other technology that is available
for confocal Imaging is multiple or
spinning disc
in this case you have a disk full of
pinholes which spins at high speed which
means that you're actually Illuminating
the sample constantly with thousands of
pinholes
and so getting an image across an entire
sensor I have a next slide to explain
this in more detail
so on the left we have a spinny
disconfocal here you can see the
spinning disc that I mentioned with
thousands of pinholes
and these pinholes are constantly
Illuminating the sample at high speed so
the sample has been illuminated the
entire sample is being illuminated
confocally if you compare this and
contrast this to the point scanning
confocal what a point scanner is doing
is Illuminating the sample a point of
light at a time scanning from left to
right or right to left and then line by
line the result is that it's capturing
an image over a longer period of time
because of the way that it scans
if you add to this
and you consider the camera technology
or the sorry the sensor technology
behind these two different types of
confocal in the case of a spinning disc
confocal and the bc43
we use scientific cameras
these cameras are able to and capture an
entire full field image
complementing the Spinning Disk and the
thousands of pinholes that were
Illuminating in a single snap
compared with that of a point scanner
which has a photo multiply tube and
therefore captures or detects a point of
light at a time
tracking and matching
in the light path the scanning laser
that's that's exciting the sample
additionally
scientific cameras have a Quantum
efficiency though so this is the ability
for the detector to capture light from
your sample
the quantum efficiency the efficiency of
capturing light is about 80 percent in
the camera of the bc43
which is considerably more than the
quantum efficiency of a photomultiplier
tube in a point scanner confocal which
is around about 45 percent QE
this does mean quite often
that in the case of a point scanner
to get an equivalent signal from the
same sample you need to
expose your sample for longer to light
and this can obviously then lead to
phototoxicity or photo bleaching which
is something I refer to earlier in my
presentation this is detrimental to
things like cell Health if you're doing
live cell Imaging and even if and if
you're Imaging thick samples for example
then you're also subject to more photo
bleaching
because you're Illuminating the sample
repeatedly as you go deeper and deeper
into the sample and so this can result
in photobleaching and losing signal
before you reach the end of your sample
depth
so the result is that for spinning disc
confocal you have a fast and highly
productive confocal system that's
approximately eight times or more
faster
than the point scanner
and this very much depends on the
resolution that you're capturing your
images at and your experimental setup
but it typically is at least eight times
or more productive having a spinning
disc confocal compared to the point
scanner
as an example of this here is a 93
Micron thick drosophila egg chamber so
there's 93 microns thick and it has two
colors in it the nuclei are stained in
yellow and then you have a cytoskeletal
structure
stained in cyan so we have two colors
that were Imaging
this 93 Micron thick sample was captured
over 309 Z planes to create the volume
and the actual resolution of the image
or the pixel Dimension is 2048 pixels by
2000 pixels and this was captured
in just over two minutes
this is really fast if you were to
compare this to a point scanner at a
light for light resolution then you
would be looking at something closer to
20 minutes or more
so in this instance we're about 10 times
faster with the bc43 than an equivalent
Point scanner confocal image
so let me tell you a little bit more
about the bc43 itself if I've seen lots
of great images so far and I've
explained the benefits of confocal
microscopy
but let's uh let's give you a bit more
information about the bc43 in terms of
the kind of experiments um and and the
benefits that it can bring to you
so first and foremost uh what's what's
great about the bt43 is Fusion the
software that drives it and captures the
images
as I mentioned earlier has the Mrs 3D
visualization engine in it this means
that we are literally able to show you
the 3D image forming as your as the
system is capturing a volume
this is great if you're setting up your
experiment and you want to quickly want
to quickly establish if you've actually
set up your for example your Z parameter
so you'll start and you'll end to
capture all of the sample you want to
image if you've set that up correctly
if you haven't then you'll quickly find
out you'll be able to stop the
experiment research your parameters and
start again
the bc43 has four excitation laser lines
405 488 561 and 637 nanometers so this
basically plays into most of the common
uh fluorophores like dappy gfp Alexa 488
RFP and Alexa 640.
for example so do all of the comma Flora
force that people are typically using
we have Borealis uniform illumination so
this is something very specific to and
or we have this both in the bc43 and
also in our higher end dragonfly uh
confocal microscopy systems Borealis
basically gives us this uniform
illumination and uniform illumination is
really important when you want when
you're wanting to well for two things
when you want to want to image large
specimens where you're going to be doing
uh tiling images and then stitching them
together into a montage in order to give
you a much larger final image of a big
sample and if you don't have uniform
uniform illumination then you can end up
with this sort of pin cushion effect
between all of the images so it doesn't
look that great
but also of course if you're wanting to
analyze an image and and using intensity
image intensity information as a means
of quantifying then you want that
intensity to be as even as possible
right to the edge of the field
particularly if you're comparing
structures uh and you want those
structures to be the same in the middle
of the field as as they are at the edges
of the field so that the intensity
information is Meaningful
for ease of use obviously now you can
see here this is a box instrument with a
lid there's no eyepieces there's not a
conventional microscope so we need to
give you some assistance in actually
finding your sample in the first place
we do have a joystick to navigate around
your sample but we also give you tools
to both find your sample in the first
place so this is focus seek and then
once you've found your sample
particularly for example in live cell
experiments we're able to then also lock
onto the sample to keep it in focus and
keep it in Focus regardless of for
example as if the regardless of the
temperature in your lab changing so we
have Focus seek and lock
we also have a quick sample overview so
this is great we start with a very low
mat at a very low magnification
objective 2x objective so this gives you
a very big macro view of your sample so
that you can then very easily set to the
area that you're interested in viewing
and then obviously zoom in with the
other objectives
in the bc43 those objectives range from
the 2x that I mentioned right up to 60x
magnification
and shortly beyond that
and also we have a built-in
anti-vibration mechanism so in the base
of the unit here we have little
anti-vibration feet and so that means
that it can live on a bench as you can
see here quite happily next to a little
mini centrifuge or it could be like a
Vortex mixer but but even with those on
the bench you're still able to continue
Imaging
so this sample is a great example of
Borealis Illumination in action
so here we have a large section of
tissue
the the tissue the image here has been
captured over 77 Z planes and at four
colors but the important part here is
that it's a stitched image so this
individual image that you're looking at
here is actually made up of 28 separate
images
that have been tiled and then stitched
together using our Stitcher in Fusion
so in total this image is what is 15 092
images
but as you can see looking at this image
there is no way you could tell that this
was made up of 28 individual tiles
it's completely seamless Imaging with
even Illumination in all wavelengths
on additional note it's worth noting
that these 15 092 images were captured
in just 30 minutes
and as I said earlier I put a typical
Point scanner would take probably take
at least six hours to capture this
this slide here is demonstrating this
the quick sample overview that we make
available to you so I mentioned earlier
that we have a 2X objective in addition
to that two objective which gives you a
nice macro view we also have something
called quick Montage so we could very
quickly do for example a three three by
three sample overview and then once you
have that three by three sample overview
you can click anywhere in the specimen
and the stage will move to that position
so that then when you move to a higher
magnification objective you're
immediately where you want it to be and
So within seconds from putting your
sample on the microscope to moving to a
high mag objective you're able to focus
and get on with capturing a volume at
that higher magnification
as I mentioned earlier we've really
tried hard to make the bc43 as easy as
possible to use and therefore have a
super fast learning curve for anybody
new to the system uh and and to get to a
point where they're Imaging a
multi-dimensional experiment as quickly
as possible
so I've already shown you that we have
some tools for starting Imaging as
quickly as possible once you've got your
sample on the microscope
I've also mentioned the fact that we
help you find and maintain the sample
focus with our Focus seek and lock
mechanism methodology
this then helps you move into
multi-dimensional acquisition and we
have a very easy to use
multi-dimensional acquisition interface
where you can capture both time
multi-channel Z stacks
multi-field multi-well and any
combination of those in a complete
experiment
and then on top of that we also have
additional processing tools such as
deconvolution
or digital clearing as some people call
it and also image stitching or montage
and in there we have the Amara Stitcher
and we can have both of these processing
tools as inline image processing so once
your experiment has completed
uh those processing tools can then start
working it does mean for example if
you've got an experiment that finishes
in the early hours of the morning then
those the image stitching and or the
deconvolution can start work overnight
so that when you come and come back into
the lab in the morning the experiment
was just finished and everything is
ready for you to review
so whilst we were testing the bc43 we
took the opportunity to obviously put it
in front of new users and compare their
learning ability on the bc43 compared
with their experience on a point scanner
confocal
and the measuring point we took was
their ability to capture
the majority of the multi-parameter or
sorry multi-dimensional Imaging
protocols so for example being able to
capture a multi-channel experiment a
multi-channel experiment with zed
multi-channel experiment over time
multi-field experiment
Etc
so we look at their ability to be able
to perform most of those different
Imaging protocols and we compare that to
point scanner and what we found was that
with some minimal tutorial and these
were just little video short videos
instructional videos for them to work
with that within an hour they were
already able to capture using all of the
Imaging protocols available to them
um
whereas in the case of a point scanning
confocal they found that it took them
longer now there is a reason for this
obviously the bc43 is a simple expert
it's a simpler system we have uh very
easy to use software the interface is
very clear clean and easy to follow and
point scanners they are more
sophisticated pieces of Kit they're
capable of doing some very clever
different Imaging techniques Etc but for
routine Imaging which is what we're
talking about and focusing on here then
the bc43 was much easier to learn to use
and consequently of course more
productive for those who are wanting to
use it so this is great for you know
going into a lab where you might have a
you know quite a turnover of project
students or you've got a new PhD
students starting and you're not as a pi
maybe for example you're not an expert
yourself so you so training them would
otherwise be a challenge if you're a
core facility manager obviously the bc43
if you need something for routine
Imaging then a bc43 is great it's for
new users to come in to start to learn
to use a confocal and it means that your
tuition time the time spent with them
tutoring them on how to use the
equipment is shortened considerably
shortened and so life becomes a little
bit easier for you as well in that
respect
here's just one example of a workflow
just to give you a sense of of the
fusion software and how easy it is to
use
so in this instance we've got a sample
on our bc43 we've taken an overview of
that sample using the lowmag objective
and then we've selected the particular
in this case drosophila embryo that
we're interested in
and then clicked that to move it to the
center of the image of the camera
then we move to a higher magnification
and when we go to higher mag and we just
do a little bit of fine focusing it'll
be already close to focus but we just do
a little final adjustment once it's on
the higher magnification objective in
this case a 40x then immediately we can
see the software that we selected
and then we're able to move to setting
up in this case a z-stack so this is the
z-stack panel here on the right where we
can set our end and our start or we can
set a center and say how many microns
each side for example we want to go and
then we just press acquire
and then that obviously ultimately
results in a final image in this
instance where this is a 3D MIP so this
is a 3D image but just squashed into a
maximum intensity projection so
therefore is a TD 2D representation of
that image
and then the interface is in three very
simple sections the image interface this
is your navigation panel so this is how
you navigate your sample your objective
selection your wavelength your exposure
uh and your XY control for moving around
the sample and then on the right hand
side here which can expand and collapse
R is where you set up your protocols
your Z Stacks your time series your
multi-well Etc
so it's a very simple workflow from left
to right
covering all the various parameters
Imaging parameters you would want to
cover
so so this is just a quick example of
the focus you can lock most specifically
the focus lock so during a live cell
experiment which can last four hours or
even days you want the microscope to
stay perfectly in focus on your sample
and things that can fight against that
for example might be changes in the in
the temperature of your laboratory so
what what Focus lock does is it locks
onto the onto the cover slip
that your sample is uh adhered to
and then if any change in temperature
happens over time to cause the sample to
go out of focus or the cover slip to
move relative to the objective then the
Focus lock mechanism will correct for
this
so in this image you can see cells are
dividing
but the cells stay perfectly in focus in
all four of these fields
so all of the data I've shown you so far
has either been a fixed samples or
relatively slow cell dynamics of live
experiments so such as cell division
however it is possible to go faster with
the bc43 either in confocal or wide
field mode and we can go up to 44 frames
per second that would be using a 10
millisecond exposure for example
and it also means that
um we can you know look at relatively
fast cellular Dynamics
so for example in this in this situation
here in this particular experiment we're
looking at gfp Tagged eb1 so this is
looking at microtubule plus tips growing
from the centrosomes of the cell that is
going into mitosis
so over time you can see quite clearly
how the microtubule tips are moving what
direction they're moving in and this
particular experiment was captured at
two frames per second over a six minute
period
and that is primarily run at that frame
rate because these were very low
expressing very low signals in this
sample so we did need to have slightly
longer exposures than your 10
milliseconds when you're running at your
fastest so obviously the the speed that
you run at is dependent upon the amount
of signal that you have and therefore
the length of your exposures but faster
Dynamic Imaging is possible with a bc43
so bc43 is really a very versatile
Imaging system so great for bringing
into the heart of your laboratory and
fantastic if your research
spans from something the scale of a cell
right through to multicellular
structures or even full organisms
so we have already with bc43 image cell
lines stem cells cell tissues organoids
drosophila zebrafish flat fish Mouse
mammalian cells
chicken cells even and many others could
be used
so there's a full scale here available
to you as researchers from using just
this one instrument
slide summarizes nicely the scales that
we're talking about so I've shown you
cell division through some multicellular
structures such as the drosophila egg
Chambers here and then right through to
being able to image whole tissue here
such as a ring of intestine
now imagine you're the owner of a bc43
and you've managed to capture all these
amazing images
what more can you do with those images
what more can you learn from these data
sets especially the 3D ones well as I
mentioned earlier Fusion saves in the
Mrs file format and Mrs is the market
leading analysis package for 3D image
visualization and Analysis
so let me show you an example here we
have a zebrafin fish model
that is looking at bone regeneration
and what's happened here is the
investigator the researchers damaged the
bone
and is looking at the Regeneration
process
the bone that you can see labeled in
magenta is newly formed bone and the
bone in green is the old original bone
additionally labeled in this sample are
osteoclasts osteoclasts are
bone-resorbing cells that help in the
repair process so all of these little
individual yellow dots are osteoclasts
and the researcher in this instance
would be interested in
the activity of the osteoclasts in
relation to the Bone repair mechanism
so how do we analyze this well first of
all we need to understand or we need to
establish the areas of the sample that
we're interested in so here
predominantly the researcher is
interested in the newly formed bone
and the little yellow dots the
osteoclasts so we need to tell a
software what to analyze
now we could use manual segmentation
which is based on intensity and manually
move sliders up and down to try and
Define this area of pink this magenta
area but why do that when you have ai or
machine learning capabilities so what we
can do is we can teach the software the
the the pattern that the pixel
distribution and pattern of this magenta
label
and by teaching the software it will
automatically then detect all of the all
of the similar pixel pixel classified
pixels that match
uh that pattern so for example if you
look to the right hand side of the image
now we've taught imaris what the magenta
area should look like from a pixel
classification perspective and it is now
automatically detecting all of these
areas of regeneration of bone
and not only that is it will go on to
shortly to also identify all of these
little osteoclasts as individual spots
so if I move on a step now you can see
if we look to images one and two on the
right you can see I've removed the raw
image and you're left with the AI
taught
regions of the newly formed bone
and in addition to that you can see that
the osteoclasts are no longer all yellow
because what we've done is we've done
spot detection in Mrs and then we've
color coded those gastroclasts according
to how close they are to the newly
formed areas in in the regenerated bone
so we're now able to look at for example
measure elements like distance from the
from the newly forming bone or the
density around the newly forming bone
if I take this a step further
what we can do just to make this a
little bit more accurate and less
subjective is that having used the pixel
classifier to determine the areas of
Interest so the regenerating bone we're
then able to also create some larger
envelopes
so let's say a perimeter vicinity that
would be localized to each of those
individual bones in the fin of the
zebrafish
and by doing so
and by sort of segmenting areas like
this
we're more easily able to then
identify those osteoclasts that are
within a useful vicinity of the
regenerating bone and then make a more
accurate calculated appraisal or
analysis of
numbers of osteoclasts within a specific
region around each of the repairing
bones
according to where they are in the
Regeneration process
so you can see for example in this
middle
uh thin bone here
we have the highest density of active
osteoclasts
and then as you move away to to the left
where
regeneration is is more complete the
osteoclast number drops and actually if
you look to the right where the bone
repair process is only just beginning
then you see that you start with low
numbers on the right hand side and then
as the Regeneration uh
progresses you see more and more
osteoclasts moving into the area of the
bone that's regenerating
and all this has been up to half of this
because the the spot detection isn't uh
AI but in terms of defining these areas
so that we can actually set up these
measurements then this is all done using
machine learning
so then your final image looks like this
so this is was the original raw data on
the left
and on the right is the segmented
machine learning segmented
um
analysis
and its visual representation in terms
of how we've segmented the image and
counted the spots relative to that
segmentation
so to summarize bc43 is a benchtopcon
focal it does however have three
modalities Imaging modalities
multi-point conf focal wide field
fluorescence microscopy and transmitted
like microscopy with bright field and
differential phase contrast
it has a small footprint so it easily
fits onto your bench
there's no need for a dark room so it
can be on a just a regular bench with uh
near windows
you can have it in the lab or the corner
of a facility
it's compact so it can fit quite easily
alongside other elements of your bench
like mini centrifuges and preparation
areas and consequently it's high
productivity so you can be Imaging one
sample whilst you're preparing the next
it has a super fast learning curve
and there's a more affordable confocal
Imaging system than most of those that
you use today
it's basically much multi-dimensional
microscopy made easy
and produces stunning 3D images in an
instance
so thank you for your time and I'm ready
to take any questions that you have
so thank you everybody for taking the
time to sit through my webinar I hope
you found it interesting
I've seen now that there's a few
questions come in so I'll start going
through those questions and notice a few
of you have asked if I actually told me
that my webinar I put my webcam on to be
a little bit more
sociable
oh sorry
there we go hello hi sorry about that so
thank you for attending
um
so I shall just go through some
questions I know there was a few
questions on can we share the
presentation either in PDF format or
recorded we certainly will be making the
recording available uh interestingly PDF
isn't something we've been asked for
before but I'm sure we can arrange that
so we will we obviously have your
questions here registered so we'll be
able to send we'll be able to contact
you directly and give you either access
to the video or or the recording of the
webinar to say or the PDF
so uh thanks for those inquiries
magnification limit I did get to
eventually Renault so um 100x is what we
at the moment we're we're actually
incorporating 100x into our into our
system we have to program objectives in
so the focus so you can lock works but
shortly 100x will be available
um
Robert is there any reason for using
lasers as opposed to high-powered LEDs
so because we are a spinning uh confocal
system we still have pin holes and so
there's we still need a certain amount
of power to get enough light through the
pinholes to the sample so at the moment
there are high powered LEDs that
probably would have enough power in them
but we need the collimated we need that
focus collimated light which we can
produce uh with a with a laser and
um
and more importantly not all not all of
the LEDs necessarily hit the high high
points uh that we want so we just we use
diode lasers in here so they're pretty
small lasers inside the unit because
that's how they fit into a single box
like this we don't have a separate laser
box or engine everything is in this one
unit so so we have stuck with lasers but
they're they're um they're just simple
diode lasers
um Nick you said uh you assume you'd
have to take the sample off to add the
oil uh actually no uh but it depends on
your sample holder if you've got a just
simply something simply uh like simple
like a glass slide with a sample on it
um and maybe one of those Universal uh
sort of slide holders that you're
familiar with there's space around
though so what we do is we've actually
built in a mechanism that once you've
found your sample and you've got it in
focus on a lower mag when you want to
add oil
basically we present you to a position
we present a position where there is no
sample where you can add oil and then
the sample moves back to exactly where
you were back into focus and you're good
to go
um
next question is how fine can the
acquired fluorescence image bandwidth
Marie
um be tuned to on this system so the the
emission bandwidths have are just
dictated by uh more you know traditional
filter bandwidths so we have we have
very specific bandwidths for uh for each
wavelength to maximize to maximize the
signal from the sample to the camera but
obviously trying to keep them as narrow
as possible to minimize any sort of
crosstalk that we might get between
um crossover between filters so I can
give you more specific details uh
offline in that regard if if you need to
um
so
um yes the quick overview of images is
also possible in wide field fluorescence
that's not a problem
you can do it in wide field in
fluorescence and in and in the
transmitted light
um
let's have a look here
uh clarified tissue a clear tissue uh
yes I mean clear so so if you're using
clear tissue I suppose clear tissues
kind of the optimum really into
optically because obviously the the more
clear the tissue the more optically
transparent it is so the the deeper we
can image so oh yeah if you can clear
your tissue then this is this is perfect
and obviously clear tissue typically is
quite thick so the speed that we can
image at we can really turn through uh
cleared samples very very effectively
foreign
[Music]
fluidics Yes actually uh theoretically
yes but we are have we we're actually
investigating as your name looks
familiar so it might be it might be you
um we're actually looking into uh the
microfluidics system so we certainly
have the space on the unit to do it it's
more a case of handling the tubing uh
Etc so um we we do believe it's possible
but but there are so many solutions out
there that we sort of need to look
closely at each one to see what we can
achieve
um so that would be a specific inquiry
to us and then we can investigate
further
uh yes we do have a lot of Portuguese
images here uh
oh sorry uh yowa yowa
um our testing was actually done uh in
one of the labs in Portugal which is why
you're seeing uh so many images from
there
um Johannes we'll come back to you on
that
uh no no so um in terms of so what are
the camera specs and can you choose
different options no we have one camera
in the bc43 and it's our uh xyla it's
our scmos camera that's in there so
um it is it's it's specifically uh that
spec so it's a scientific scmos
um if you want we can give you more
specific detail on that camera offline
how many emission filters at the moment
we have four emission filters so we have
an emission filter for each excitation
wavelength
so that's answering Bernard's question
uh as to the cost we will again come to
you directly on that because that
depends on where in the world you are so
uh we can we can reach out directly on
that question
there are maintenance contracts
available there's a whole range of
different options in terms of the level
of of cover that you want so again we
can reach out to you directly on that
and give you an idea of the price ranges
um share the copy share oh gosh we've
got lots of questions coming in
um
yeah so uh
uh durgesh uh a question about can we
image plant samples we have actually
image we've imaged some root tips uh and
we have oh I can't remember the other
sample we've we've tried we haven't done
we haven't done so many we weren't able
to test during it was due to lockdown we
we didn't really test much in the way of
plant samples but we can we certainly
can do we've certainly missed some root
tip and we can certainly pick up the
auto fluorescence and a lot of a lot of
plant samples like conval area Etc so so
evidence tells us we can
um so it's uh The Next Step would be
obviously just trying it depends what
plant samples you have I know some some
samples can be more challenging than
others depending on auto fluorescence in
the sample and the wavelengths you're
trying to to image
so I need the drink
so Simon I think that probably
answers your question this is bc43 is a
very new product so at the moment we
don't have any existing customers using
it for Plant Imaging so all we have some
of the experience we've experiences
we've had in demoing
but obviously please get in touch with
us if you want to find out more about
what we have done already
um no we can't add other lasers so the
idea of the system is that it it remains
simple and compact so in doing so we
have had to restrict the laser
combinations but then that's why we have
we have our other uh Series so we have
our dragonfly series our dragonfly
series you can have up to eight
different wavelengths to cover all sorts
of fluorophores right up into the nir so
into the like sort of 780 nanometer end
as well
um so so that's really sort of the
difference between the bc43 and why
somebody might still want to invest in
something like our dragonfly series
which again is a high speed confocals
very productive because those give you
much more flexibility in your choice you
can choose different camera types for
different sensitivities low light
fluorescence you know regular
fluorescence and then a whole multitude
of lasers and filter choices Etc
uh and also on the dragonfly series you
can actually also start to add things
like Photo stimulation devices and
ablation and DNA damage things like this
which which again you wouldn't be able
to do on a bc43
um
over The Late how long were the lasers
last the lasers last for uh thousands of
hours
um
bottom line is that they last for they
should they should well depends on your
usage so it's really hard to to answer
the question technically but what we
have in
in the bc43s we use a system and also in
our dragonflies we use a system called
active blanking so we only have the
laser light on when we're exposing the
sample and taking an image so even in a
z-stack we would switch the laser off
while we move and move to a new Z
position and then switch it back on to
capture the image so the actually the
the amount of time the laser is on is is
you know minimize is completely kept to
a minimum so so technically unless you
know there's some technical issue with
the lasers and I guess anything can
break down in real life uh then there's
thousands of hours uh of of lifespan on
these on these lasers
uh there isn't a wide field only version
available of uh for this uh bc43
um at the moment we just have the the
full three modalities Bernard
uh file format is the
um
so I'm just looking at the time the file
format is Mrs so it's dot IMS format so
it is it is the Mrs format we do so what
happens is with the bc43 we also Supply
a very um sort of a basic version of the
Mrs that allows you to visualize to
create movies to take snapshots Etc so
there you could always convert into
other file format
from there uh
yes uh so johanna's question on um
environmental control yes so what we can
do is we can put a stage Stop incubator
inside the bc43 on the side here I'm not
sure if you're seeing my presentation
slide here but on the side here we have
a little space where we can pull the CH
we can have the tubes for uh for the
temperature sensor and the gas the CO2
Etc humidity and so yes we can keep
cells alive for days potentially uh on
on the unit and we can control for 37
degrees C and you can have different
incubation options to regulate that five
percent CO2 sorry different gas control
options I should say to regulate the CO2
um
can it be read through bio formats for
example Matia the file format that we
have
um
well I should know that off the top of
my head but my memory is failing me I
think so but it would be best if I go
away and check and give you more
specific detail because I know sometimes
there's a little bit of a route into
buyer format so um we'll come back to
you on that matchup
uh the price again uh ramiza I will
reach out directly because it depends
again what country you're in what region
you're in ETC and what currency we're
working in
uh is this the whole system or are there
some accessory so this is this is but
what you're seeing is is
essentially the whole system but there
are some accessories so the accessories
would be the environmental control not
everybody wants the environmental
control
um and also obviously there's a choice
of objectives
um so there's up to five positions uh in
the nose piece but you choose the
objectives that are relevant to your
experimental needs and then also around
the workstation we have some you know
additional data storage options for
example uh that you can choose there as
well so not many additional options but
there are some
um zebrafish is supposed to do live
Imaging I'm gonna have to probably stop
on the question shortly uh is it
possible to do life's love oh yes uh
other dish not slight yes so actually we
did do some um fish lava uh Imaging uh
we have we have got I think a movie set
that we tried on the bc43 during testing
uh frustratingly as you probably know if
you do that Imaging it didn't always
stay where we wanted it to
it was a little bit Lively at least a
couple of times that we had a go we
didn't quite get the anesthetic and the
gel
um I guess concentration right so uh so
it is possible we do have some movies in
the end and so we have image of those
um
no uh frap and frat experiments would
not be something that you could easily
do on the bc43 uh uh uh erwan
uh
uh yeah so work so Ahmed you're asking
about workshops uh again it depends
where you are but we are very very
active with bc43 our sales team at the
moment are setting up workshops and
doing Road shows and arranging demos so
we will be
um so so yeah so we we have your details
so what we can do is we can give your
contact details to the regional
representative representative from Andor
and they can reach out and get in touch
with you
sorry excuse me a second I'm going to
cough
thank you
um
okay I think that's pretty much the end
of the so anything around uh pricing
we'll reach out to you directly because
as I said that's that sort of regional
that's down to different currencies Etc
as to as to what that is and I don't
have all the currencies off the top of
my head so we'll reach out to you
specifically uh on that so um thank you
all very much for your time thank you
for your questions it's good always good
to see questions it means that so that
you have been there somebody's been
listening to me I'm watching my
presentation so thank you very much if
you have any more questions
um you can still you know we will say
We'll record these anyway and we'll get
we'll reach out to you but um failing
that you can you you can always put
inquiries via our web pages as well so
if you go onto our web pages and onto
the bc43 page even for example you can
you can request more information or
pricing Etc so
um yeah that's not a problem you don't
you don't miss out on the opportunity
just because you haven't been able to to
ask here
okay well thank you very much and we
will wrap that up now thank you